donc c'est vrai que sur le principe à la
base comme ça on regarde on dit puces à
12 lieux ni qui annonce bionique bon
fondamentalement il n'y a pas vraiment
de différence et pourtant s'il ya une
vraie vraie vraie belle différence est
la différence
elle se fait vraiment mais vraiment sûr
[Musique]
regardez moi ce que je suis aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui peut bien y avoir à
l'intérieur au revoir à
j'aime beaucoup 1 2 je vous laisse
deviner ce qu'il peut y avoir à
l'intérieur un indice vous avez remarqué
depuis quelques temps on parle beaucoup
d'ordinateurs différents ordinateurs
portables et du coup on voit qu'on va
continuer puisque aujourd'hui on reçoit
laptop de l'espace désolé donald reçoit
deux experts de chez dell
on va tester on doit avoir normalement
un écran oled un écran lcd
donc on va prendre le temps de regarder
tous en détail sa torche format compact
regardez-moi ça intel core i7 petit gars
mais là on va regarder ça d'ici quelque
temps tout petit bordure donc d'ici
quelques temps on va checker ces deux
nouveaux produits de dell donc bon je
vous invite à faire une seule chose
c'est bien évidemment vous abonner comme
ça on va grandissant détails mais
aujourd'hui on n'est pas venu pour
parler de dell
on pourrait mais c'est pas le but du jeu
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on va comparer
deux iphone l'iphone 10 de l'année
dernière et l'iphone 10s de cette année
parce que même s'ils se ressemblant
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de points
soit quand même différent pas énormément
mais un peu différente mais sous ces
petites différences qui paraissent
franchement no deal se cachent de
réelles différences alors réelle
différence oui et non parce qu'on est
sûr ou
me génération il faut savoir maintenant
samsung apple ces constructeurs laon des
produits demi génération c'est-à-dire
vous sortent des produits relativement
différent avec de réelles nouveautés
tous les deux ans donc on est une vraie
nouveauté les dernières avec l'arrivée
de l'iphone disque un petit peu le
modèle qui est censé donner un peu la
ligne chez apple pour les dix ans à
venir
et là avec cet iphone 10 s on est sur
une semi évolution alors il ya eu des
semis évolution beaucoup plus évolutive
là sur le coup c'est franchement pas la
grosse révolution mais néanmoins qu'on
peut pas dire qu'elle parle d'évolution
relativement faut donc qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va regarder ces évolutions
en cinq points et vous allez voir malgré
tout cet iphone 10 aces a plus d'un tour
dans son sac
le premier point qui fait la différence
c'est la solidité et la résistance
autant dire directement c'est un point
qu'on ne voit absolument pas apple nous
annoncer un verre beaucoup plus
résistant sans les fon 10 16 par rapport
à l'iphone 10 du pas mal de drop tests
qui ont été publiés sur internet les
c'est qu'il est beaucoup plus
résistantes il peut prendre des chocs
sans coque et ne pas casser
et ça pour le coup c'est peut être
plutôt pas mal parce que combien d'entre
vous à commencer par mois se sont
retrouvés chez les réparateurs pour
avoir pété soit la face avant sur la
face arrière du coup ça fait toujours
râler parce que l'addition malgré tout
et quand même salle et donc là on a un
iphone 10s plus résistant que l'iphone
10 entre point qui est intéressant c'est
la certification ip on est sur une
certification ip67 sur l'iphone 10 de
l'année dernière une certification il
pèse 68 sur l'iphone 10s de cette année
alors me direz-vous entre une
certification ip67 et ip 68 ou disent
que ça va vraiment pas grand chose pour
moi alors dans l'absolu non la toute
première idée de la certification
étaient 68 là dessus je dirais c'est se
mettre un peu à un niveau de la
concurrence tous les constructeurs
aujourd'hui sur les produits haut de
gamme et très haut de gamme
on les certifications et qu'à 68 bien
peu que apple qui reste un peu derrière
avec la certification ip67 et pourtant a
produit vendu beaucoup plus cher que le
reste du marché
l'idée simple de se mettre à niveau de
certains les critiquent deuxième point
non négligeable sans forcément le
téléphone beaucoup plus robuste
puisqu'il est capable d'être immergé
plus longtemps en plus grande profondeur
alors l'idée c'est effectivement pas de
le jeter dans votre bocal de poissons
rouges dans les toilettes et puis j'irai
la chercher tout ce que vous voulez mais
tout simplement si un accident devait
arriver vous seriez en tout cas plus
tranquille potentiellement sur notre
faim dit c'est ce que sur l'iphone 10
donc ça c'est pour le premier point
deuxième différence se fait du côté du
design c'est vrai d'un point de vue
purement design et les deux se
ressemblent énormément à peu l'affection
qu'on servait exactement le même design
pour ce modèle 5,8 pouces au niveau de
l'écran les dimensions sont les mêmes le
modèle de cette année est légèrement
plus lourd de quelque chose comme 4 g
fondamentalement on peut dire qu'ils
font quasiment au même point ça change
absolument rien donc on est vraiment
deux iphone qui sont vraiment très très
très similaires la différence que vous
allez avoir alors au delà des nouvelles
couleurs et de trouver notamment de
couleur or sur l'iphone 10s la vraie
différence se fait au niveau des
antennes
autant vous dire que c'est du point de
détail là vous avez ici à l'iphone dit
c'est cela vous avez l'iphone dit vous
voyez ici vous avez une petite
différence au niveau des antennes vous
retrouver exactement à la même
différence ici au niveau du lot mais
sinon vous le prenez sur la tranche
c'est exactement le même produit
également pour l'arrière est absolument
aucun changement donc d'un point de vue
purement esthétique ce sont vraiment les
mêmes appareils
troisième point et non des moindres
c'est la performance alors c'est quelque
chose qui est quand même relativement
difficile à mesurer directement parce
que les deux produits sont performants
vous avez ici la puce à 11 bionis de
l'année dernière bionic première
génération la puce à 12 bionique de
cette année bionic deuxième génération
alors pourquoi bionique c'est pour le
north island jeunes pour l'intelligence
artificielle ça fait plein de choses
super c'est très pratique très rapide ça
marche très bien dans les deux cas c'est
très compliqué à mesurer directement
lorsque vous l'utilisez on va pouvoir un
petit peu aller le chercher dans l'air
franchement notamment avec des
applications de réalité augmentée c'est
extrêmement fluide très très très fluide
j'ai fait pas mal de tests directement
sur l'iphone bicesse et puis vous
assurer que ça marche absolument bien
moi je vous fais la démo avec l'iphone
10 s max à la même chose mais c'est
juste pour profiter du plus grand écran
et voyez ce qui est complètement dingue
là je voulais utiliser la réalité
augmentée avec un petit lego on se
rapproche on peut se baigner tout autour
c'est vraiment hyper bluffant ça marche
extrêmement bien et on voit vraiment là
dessus tout la capacité de calcul parce
qu'il s'intègre complètement un
environnement et c'est vraiment vraiment
génial ça marche super bien ça calcul
très très rapidement et ne serait ce que
pour faire tout ça croyez moi derrière
il faut la capacité de calcul et c'est
vraiment là dessus que c'est hyper hyper
hyper bluffant pour la synthèse souvent
tout pour voir vraiment la différence
3 ils partent exactement en même temps
on va voir lequel a le plus gros score
alors à mon avis très clairement avec la
nouvelle brouille est directement déjà y
ait un écart entre la puce à 12 bionic
et la puce à 11 bionique d'un côté puis
on verra à la fin lequel ce corps va
directement sur le tartan votre iphone
10 aces a pris un peu d'avancé par
rapport à l'iphone 10 néanmoins il n'est
pas non plus une énorme claque l'iphone
dit c'est juste derrière malgré tout une
différence notable mais je dirais que
pour l'utilisation standard pour nous ce
sera vraiment du point de détail parce
que les deux sont vraiment excellents la
f10 est finie le test en avant suivi de
très très très près par l'iphone 10
alors le score est sans appel quand même
d'un côté sur l'iphone 10 s on a le
score de 350 7177 sûr en tout qui est
quand même énorme
tandis que l'autre côté on a le score de
148 1831 fait exactement dans les mêmes
conditions avec la même version 2to
benchmark la v7 pour 1.2 donc on va
vraiment là-dessus sur un test comme ça
la différence entre un défaut 10 aces et
un iphone 10 après un test comme ça on
sent là ils ont chauffé ici ils sont
chaudes tous les deux exactement la même
manière donc rien de bien surprenant à
savoir que là dessus
vous avez aussi un fake saïdi sur iphone
10 aces un fake saïdi nouvelle
génération plus rapide et plus sécurisé
bon une fois de plus à l'ouverture
franchement je ne vois absolument aucune
différence comme ça il ya néanmoins une
petite différence qui censurent l'iphone
10 de l'année dernière vous avez 3 giga
de ram tandis que sur l'iphone 10s de
cette année vous avez 4 gigas de ram
donc une puce à 12 bionique nouvelle
génération à 11 bionique ancienne
génération 4 gigas de ram 3 ya drame
on le voit c'est sans appel il ya
beaucoup plus de puissance et de
performances là dessus par contre par
contre et c'est l'aube ce qui est
intéressant c'est pour l'utilisation
quotidienne pour vous pour ce que vous
allez en faire fondamentalement vous
sentirez je pense dans 90% des cas
absolument pas la différence
autre point différent ce qui est
intéressant c'est l'appareil photo pas
tant au niveau des capteurs qu'est-ce
que dans les deux cas vous avez un
capteur 12 mégapixels au niveau du
grand-angle et 12 mégapixels au niveau
du téléobjectif les ouvertures sont les
mêmes par contre la différence se fait
vraiment au niveau logiciel sans
l'iphone 10s vous avez le smart hdr vous
pouvez aussi faire de la post prod
directement au niveau de l'eph évoqué
lorsque vous avez pris votre photo vous
pouvez modifier le flou d'arrière-plan
le régler comme vous voulez fou - fous
pas fou du tout vous choisissez tandis
que là dessus vous ne l'avez pas sur les
photos ça se vaut
il ya une vraie différence et je vous
demande tout de suite là vous avez une
photo avec le smart hdr là vous avez la
photo sans le smart hdr mais avec le hdr
du modèle de l'année dernière et là il
ya une vraie vraie différence qui sépare
ce que sur la photo avec le smart hdr
les couleurs sont beaucoup plus rendu il
ya beaucoup moins de deux zones d'ombré
il y a des couleurs qui sont beaucoup
plus vives et on voit au final une vraie
grosse belle différence sur les photos
qui est vraiment prise exactement dans
les mêmes conditions de luminosité
on peut changer de photo vous voyez
c'est exactement la même chose on voit
là vous avez plus de zones d'ombré au
milieu un peu à gauche en bas au milieu
à gauche vous n'avez pas sur les photos
avec le smart hdr et ça c'est vraiment
appréciable la même sauf que vous aller
photographier un ciel ça c'est super
intéressant parce que vous voyez que
vous avez beaucoup de détails au niveau
du sapin que vous n'avez pas de l'autre
côté donc le smart à gien va vraiment
faire son boulot et c'est vraiment là
dessus que ce intéressant et même dans
le ciel il ya beaucoup plus de détails
d'une manière générale les couleurs sont
quand même beaucoup plus belle beaucoup
plus préservé et ça marche vraiment bien
vachement intéressant c'est une photo en
éclairage naturel en mode portrait que
la caméra de celle ci et vous allez voir
le rendu est fondamentalement différent
sur l'iphone dix c'est beaucoup plus
contrasté j'ai ici est en train d'avoir
un oeil au beurre noir tandis que la
absolument pas et pourtant ces prix
exactement dans les mêmes conditions
à quelques secondes d'intervalle en plus
au niveau du flou je suis beaucoup mieux
des tours et sur l'iphone dit c'est ce
que sur l'iphone 10 et voyez en termes
de photos termes de traitement d'image
c'est pas du tout la même chose et c'est
vraiment beaucoup mieux au point qui est
super intéressant là dessus c'est que
vous pour le modifier
vous avez aussi la possibilité de
changer votre iphone arrière-plan en
post production c'est à dire qu'il ya
vraiment un vrai gros gros travail qui
est fait aussi du point de vue logiciel
tandis que l'as absolument pas possible
alors vous pouvez changer après vos
éclairages anthos prod
mais malgré tout on peut pas tout faire
là dessus alors vous allez voir c'est
vachement intéressant parce que au
niveau du détourage on voit vraiment ici
regardez ça vient me manger un petit
bout d'oreille là tandis que là ça me
mange absolument pas debout d'oreilles
donc le détourage est vraiment beaucoup
mieux fait au niveau de l'iphone 10 16
par rapport à l'iphone 10 et c'est
vraiment là dessus qu'on voit vraiment
tout la performance toute la puissance
de cette puce à 12 bio
du traitement logiciel qui est collée
derrière par rapport à l'iphone 10 de
l'année dernière c'est du point de
détail mais sur la photo croyez-moi ça
vraiment son importance et on ne voit
vraiment sur des résultats là c'est sans
appel
donc c'est vrai que son principe à la
base comme ça on regarde on dit puces à
12 lieux ni cas où ce bionic vont
fondamentalement n'y a pas vraiment de
différence et pourtant s'il ya une vraie
vraie vraie belle différence est la
différence
elle se fait vraiment mais vraiment sur
les photos et ça c'est sans appel sur un
mode portrait sur un détourage sur le
smart hdr il ya une vraie grosse belle
différence donc si vous êtes vraiment un
amoureux de photos et que vous devez
changer votre smartphone alors s'envole
détaillant quelques instants pour voir
vraiment dans quel cas de figure il faut
aller sur l'iphone 10s je pense que tous
les cas de figure sont pas
nécessairement très intéressant on va
râler sein des si quelques secondes
en tout cas les faux 10s un vrai car est
un vrai intérêt par rapport à l'iphone
10 il ya aussi une différence qui se
fait au niveau de l'audio dans les deux
cas vous avez des hauts parleurs stéréo
mais dans le cas de l'iphone 10 s vous
avez des hauts parleurs stéréo qui use
beaucoup plus avec une plus grande
amplitude sonore plus de basses une
meilleure qualité de son et ça pour vous
le faire écouter on a changé le micro
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est donc une vraie différence de son
antre l'iphone dit c'est l'iphone disent
ça c'est incroyable parce que là dessus
on a l'impression que sont un peu plus
étouffé un peu plus petit il ya la
puissance peut pas dire qu'il n'a pas
mais malgré tout dès qu'on passe en live
10 aces c'est beaucoup plus large
beaucoup plus d'immersion beaucoup plus
sympa et ça c'est vraiment cool d'autant
plus que la cure en plus vous avez un
enregistrement en stéréo et ça c'est
aussi plutôt bien
cinquième point maintenant non
négligeable tout ce qui est un peu
autres alors à savoir que sur l'iphone
10 s
vous avez une plus grosse capacité de
stockage disponible si vous souhaitez
aller dessus vous pouvez monter jusqu'en
512 giga vous pouvez faire ça beau
coûter cher mais vous pouvez le faire
voilà ça c'est une possibilité
là dessus vous étiez en 256 marx qui
était déjà très très bien pas
nécessairement l'intérêt de passer en
512 en plus si vous êtes sur le cloud
bon voilà ça ça reste à voir
autre point intéressant là dessus avec
cet iphone 10 aces mais qui laisse un
peu sur ma faim c'est la possibité
d'abord double non n'appelle pas les
secours n'appelle pas les secours elle
n'appelle pas les secours merci série je
n'ai pas besoin de ce qu'on change juste
une vidéo la secret story 5 est toujours
pour moi j'appelle les secours mais
n'ont pas le droit aux horaires quoique
les pompiers car est vrai qu'avec ce qui
vous arrive absolument rien calme-toi
série tout va bien merci beaucoup
bon alors je vous disais le but je me
ressaisisse ce que je vous disais c'est
que vous avez la cousine la possibilité
d'avoir ici une double carte sim
oui et non double carte sim réel en
chine ça c'est vrai par contre dans le
reste du monde c'est une simple carte
sim plus unie sim une carte sim
virtuelle ou avoir effectivement deux
numéros mais c'est pas une réelle double
carte sim comme on peut la voir sur
beaucoup de produits du marché actuel
donc là dessus c'est un pas qui est fait
en avant par apple c'est bien ou mais
pas assez il faut aller un petit peu
plus loin autre point qui est bien cette
fois ci c'est apple qui nous annonce une
autonomie rallongée de 30 minutes dans
l'essonne dit à l'iphone 10s ça je
trouve ça plutôt cool alors c'est bien
oui moi j'étais très surpris et je vous
le dis dans mon test j'ai utilisé
notamment sur l'iphone 10 s max c'est
une économie qui étaient hallucinantes
alors je n'ai pas beaucoup utilisé
beaucoup dans la poche de temps en temps
pour les réseaux sociaux quelques emails
mon relevé de compteur de tubes et
compagnie mais je les pousser
vraiment beaucoup plus que ce qui est
annoncé et c'est en tout cas c'est super
cool donc l'option point de vue
autonomie je suis quand même aussi
relativement content même si entre les
deux il n'y a pas une valise et ça
dépend effectivement une fois de plus de
votre consommation
par contre il ya un point qui me gêne et
qu'il pose problème c'est que je trouve
qu'on a perdu quelque chose sur cet
iphone 10 sc l'adaptateur lightning vers
port jack qui a disparu c'est dommage je
l'utilisais je l'utilisé peut-être que
beaucoup d'hommes ne l'utilisent pas en
bloc la stratégie d'apple sera
clairement de faire disparaître tous les
appareils à priziac on dégage tout ça et
on vous remplacer sa part des casques
avec du bluetooth 5.0 puisque vous avez
des bluetooth 2.0 l'intérieur donc voila
un petit peu la stratégie d'apple de ce
côté là moi qui suis quand même très
attaché à mon câble qui pendouille bon
là peut-être que c'est moi qui fais un
peu le lieu-dit nommé je pense que je ne
suis pas le seul là dessus casser la
gueule voilà donc pour ces cinq points
de différence majeure entre ces deux
iphone l'iphone 10 l'iphone 10 s à la
question doit-on acheté cet iphone 10s
je vois trois cas de figure principaux
et qui sont vraiment très important vous
me direz dans lequel vous vous situez
appréhendant commentaires dans l'idée où
on a envie de l'acheter qui nous fait de
l'oeil en tout cas si on veut pas
l'acheter la question ne se pose pas
donc comme ça c'est réglé au parc bisous
bisous au revoir allemand si la question
se pose d'achat sur iphone 10 s il ya
trois cas de figure le premier c'est
vous et d'un iphone 10 de l'année
dernière et stephen 10s vous fait de
l'oeil
vous avez envie de l'acheter je vous
dirais non non ne changeait pas à moins
que vous ayez vraiment énormes besoins
en photo et vous voulez vraiment
amélioré significativement vos photos
auquel cas je vous dirais dessus d'aller
acheter un appareil photo ça pourrait
franchement vous aider mais je vois pas
vraiment l'intérêt parce que même si
effectivement cet appareil est plus
puissant permet de faire plus de choses
vraiment d'améliorer significativement
les photos par rapport à l'iphone de
l'année dernière sur l'utilisation jeudi
à long terme d'applications en terme de
jeu en terme de fluidité
vous ne sentirez quasiment pas la
différence le fait de passer de la 11e à
la 12e
oui c'est très bien
ça change pas bien le monde 3 giga de
ram 4 gigas de ram c'est bien une fois
de plus ça change pas non plus la face
du monde et puis il n'y a pas un peu de
produit un effet whaou il n'y a pas de
produits où on va se dire il n'ya pas
d'application on va dire voir ça c'est
bien ça apporte vraiment grande
nouveauté cet iphone 10 aces a vraiment
passé un cap un papa rapport avec le
dise et dans ce cas là très clairement
ça y est pas donc je ne vois pas du tout
pourquoi passer dans les feux de 10,1
d'iphone qui sait si ce n'est jeté
l'argent par les fenêtres et améliorant
sa photo je vois pas l'intérêt alors par
contre si vous avez un produit de chez
apple qui est d'une ancienne génération
je dirais jusqu'à l'iphone 7,7 plus le 8
vous avez qu à lui la langue bionique
donc ça marche aussi très bien avec le 8
et 8 plus qui va manquer un peu c'est le
design cédée look qui sont en cause
school par contre en terme de puissance
ça marche extrêmement bien photo vidéo
c'est aussi top donc si vous avez un
produit je dirais antérieure à l'iphone
8 vous pouvez changer sans aucun
problème parce que là vous serez pas
déçus c'est un excellent produit tout en
sachant que vous pouvez aussi trouver
des iphone disent non plus chez apple
parce qu'ils les font plus directement
mais chez d'autres revendeurs
ça peut être intéressant pour acheter un
iphone 10 dans la gamme 10 moins cher à
ce dernier qu'elle figure et non des
moindres vous avez un produit autre
qu'un produit de chez apple et vous
voulez passer chez apple et ses iphone
10s vous fait de l'oeil
auquel cas vous pouvez y aller si vous
n'avez pas un produit qui périt par
essence c'est un excellent produit je
vous le recommande
il est très bien fabriqué il est très
complet il marche super bien il est très
cher ça c'est clair mais par contre
derrière vous a vraiment super
smartphone dont vous pouvez y aller les
yeux fermés
voilà donc aujourd'hui pour cette
faillite entre l'iphone 10 de l'année
dernière et l'iphone 10,16 de cette
année l'iphone deuil dernière est malgré
tout très très très actuelle le design
est quasiment inchangé les performances
sont là les photos la vidéo tout est
très bien donc si vous l'avez conserver
le si l'on se laisse ici vous fait de
l'oeil pouvez y aller parce que c'est
vraiment un excellent produit
voilà pour ces deux produits alors je
vous invite à rester connectés et à vous
abonner parce que d'ici quelques jours
on va tester l'iphone 10r que le produit
low cost de chez apple de cette année
avec différentes couleurs on devrait
prendre le rouge en main ça c'est plutôt
cool et j'aime beaucoup ses gammes raid
contre toujours un peu en début d'année
en mars chez apple là on l'a directement
quelque 10 r ils ont mis directement ça
c'est bien on en reparlera parce que red
c'est une association qui lutte contre
le vih aux etats unis apple un
partenariat avec red dont tout s'est
plutôt pas mal donc on en parle vous
invite donc à faire une seule chose
c'est bien évidemment à rester connectés
à vous abonner soyez ça je vous embrasse
et à très bientôt
[Musique]